blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman so we've talked before about how
different social media networks
seem to appeal to particular demographic
groups and seem to be responsible for
the spread of different
types of disinformation and propaganda
one thing we know about facebook
specifically
is that in the 2016 election with regard
to
hillary versus trump type propaganda and
fake news
and during 2020 with regard to the
pandemic
anti-vaxx propaganda etc facebook was a
really big
player and factor in the disinformation
and fake news and propaganda that was
read
believed and signal boosted by
older americans and indeed for some
period of time now donald trump has been
banned from twitter as well as facebook
and other platforms we will know
tomorrow whether donald trump will be
allowed back on facebook and i know that
it may seem
in some sense trivial but because we
know i mean listen
um trump followers fell
for the grift of donating to fight the
election results to the tune of what was
it 60-something 70-something million
dollars
in part because uh of the campaigns on
platforms
like facebook and indeed the facebook
oversight board
has reportedly already decided but we'll
be announcing tomorrow morning
whether donald trump uh donald trump's
facebook account
will be reinstated there was this idea
previously
that at it because of what facebook said
when they banned trump
it was an indefinite suspension because
of the risk of allowing trump to
continue on the platform in terms of
violence and in terms of incitement
but that the language was about the
right now
in the aftermath of the january 6th uh
riots
in fact on january 7th but that it would
be revisited in the future and indeed
that revisitation has taken place
place and we are going to know tomorrow
the impact of this could be huge
because donald trump has been relegated
to putting out
these written statements on presidential
former presidential letterhead
they read like tweets without a doubt um
but he has not had that core audience to
share them you sort of need to go and
find them
uh or you need to be following certain
accounts that are signal boosting them
if donald trump is indeed back on
facebook this is going to reopen the
door
to all sorts of weaponized
disinformation and propaganda
it could play a role in the 2022
election given donald trump's
clear desire to be a sort of king maker
and
to see the people he supports win in
2022. so this is not
a a trivial decision um it has
reportedly already been made
and you can be absolutely sure that if
donald trump is allowed back on facebook
it's also going to put some pressure
on other social media platforms to allow
donald trump back on because the
listen i i'm the first to admit it's
unusual that a former president is
banned from all of these platforms i
don't think it's a free speech issue
every single one of these platforms as
i've talked about before has every legal
right
to say violations of our terms of
service
are going to be met with consequences
regardless of whether it's a former
president or not
but it's so trump is so unusual in how
he used these platforms to spread this
disinformation
and we now find ourselves in the really
weird situation where
the the former president is not able to
use these platforms so the pressure if
facebook says trump's coming back on
for twitter and youtube and whoever else
to say we're also letting trump back on
that the danger has passed so to speak
is going to be significant so we'll see
what that decision is that's made
tomorrow
we'll of course uh very quickly i think
see what
use donald trump plans to make of these
platforms and although in the aftermath
of these bans
donald trump has said he's happy not
being on them things are better or he's
you know whatever i think it's
abundantly clear that if given the
opportunity he will immediately start
making use of those platforms
this one is just an absolute beauty that
in a sense
doesn't surprise me but it seems like it
would be satire if you didn't know any
better
during a recent segment on fox news a
fox news anchor
asked republican senator mike braun from
indiana
whether joe biden's economy is
essentially
too good for joe biden to be doing the
things that he wants to do
this is hilarious for several reasons
which we will get to
now as many of you know the stock market
which donald trump told us would crash
if joe biden became president
has actually hit record highs new
unemployment claims
are the lowest they've been since the
start of the pandemic and they're going
lower every single week
joe biden's vaccination plan is really
popular
joe biden's coronavirus stimulus package
which passed in march
is very popular joe biden's proposed
infrastructure package is quite popular
and things are just recovering and sort
of boring
and increasingly looking good it doesn't
mean we've solved every problem or even
nearly that but
in terms of comparing to what was going
on under trump things are looking pretty
good
so here is a fox news host saying
the stock market's doing great
unemployment is down
why is joe biden doing things isn't it
dangerous to be doing things when the
economy is booming
it's almost like things are too good
take a look at this
we are seeing a booming american economy
whether it's the jobs market the the dow
as you see on your screen there
continues to hit record highs
you've got wages moving higher so why
is it that this administration wants to
spend all this money when it seems
things are getting better well that's a
good question because
the real consequences will be felt
probably post 2022
and they're calculating all this
expertly in my mind
politically isn't that just something
else
all of this time they've been denying
that things are actually going well
and now all of a sudden with concern
they
say oh i don't know the economy is
booming
the stock market's booming the job
market is recovering
and yet joe biden wants to do all this
stuff i don't know that sounds like it
could be
dangerous to do things when the economy
is doing so well
and mike braun of course throwing in
well you know the stuff joe biden wants
to do
won't be good in the long term it might
get him to 2022 in good shape
but it's not going to be good in the
long term which is a consideration
that they never make when they are
pulling their hair-brained economic
policy when a republican is in power
they are so desperate that it's actually
hilarious
oh no the economy's booming and yet
joe biden still is doing things it's
beyond parody
they are essentially admitting that
biden
is so good at running the country he
shouldn't even really be doing anything
else
and the fact that he's trying to should
really concern all of us
the economy is doing dangerously well
under joe biden and that could be a
disaster
now there's also a serious thing here
which is of course
a lot of the jobs that are coming back
for now
are coming back part-time they were
full-time many of these jobs why well
we're in the middle of a pandemic
recovery and as as industries start to
open as different sectors start to open
some of these jobs will come back not
provisionally but on a part-time basis
many businesses operating
with reduced hours the recovery has been
disproportionately better
for the very rich than it has for
everybody else it's been real the
pandemic has been really good for the
ultra super rich and it has been that
kind of k-shaped
recovery that we've talked about before
much of the stock market performance
which has been stellar
goes to the very rich so there is a real
question
which is even though the economy is
doing quite well
for wealthy people what about everybody
else and that's exactly what joe biden's
spending programs are trying to work on
but we are at a point where even doing
well now
is considered bad if you then can
continue trying to do more things as joe
biden is trying to do
they have nothing else to whine about
we've gotten to the
is the economy too good part
of the joe biden presidency and it's
only like on month
four they were just trying to give trump
credit for the economy last week
now it's well this is biden's economy
but it's almost like it's doing
so well something must be about to go
wrong or it must be terrible for joe
biden to keep trying to do stuff
if you were to write a saturday night
live script about how
fox news would cover the circumstances
now uh four months in three four months
in to joe biden's presidency
it would be indistinguishable from is
the economy doing dangerously well and
that's exactly what we're getting on fox
news
let me know what you think they will go
to next
in the manufactured crisis find me on
twitter
deepakman what if you could read
10 books in just one sitting that's
exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and
a subscription is only about eight bucks
a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to
slash blinkist.com pakman i've put the
link right underneath this video
hey uh feel free if you're so inclined
to grab
a membership on my website
joinpackman.com
it feels great it's cheap it's quick
it's our primary source of funding on an
ongoing basis
and you get the daily bonus show
award-winning
uh as just one of many great membership
benefits join
at joinpakman.com coupon code
availablenevermandatory
better21 saves you a bundle
okay today we're going to look at a
super interesting interview with a
republican senator
actually being forced to go beyond the
talking points when
questioned by fox news host chris
wallace
it's really easy to simply say
you know we can't increase the deficit
we don't have the money for things
democrats want to do
where is the money going to come from
now of course we know that they never
ask those questions when it's about
defense spending or war or tax cuts for
the rich we know about that double
standard
but it doesn't matter because if they're
not questioned about those talking
points
there are lots of people who buy it hey
yeah billions hundreds of billions that
sounds crazy
how do we afford this stuff and if
they're not questioned about it
they never really have to explain what
they mean and you get a lot of
republican voters
who end up agreeing with you now
similarly when republicans say
biden's infrastructure plan is too
expensive
it's not all really infrastructure it's
filled with crap
when they say biden's job plan is just
spending money we don't have
it's easy as long as you never have to
explain
anything but when you do have to explain
well okay
which of these things would you cut
which of these are not worthy
elements for this plan something
interesting happens
first of all they almost never have
actual answers and secondly
it throws them off so badly that they
often
end up exposing other garbage talking
points
that they also typically are allowed to
get away with so let's dive right in
this is fox host chris wallace asking
republican senator bill cassidy
all right uh senator sir which specific
parts
of the biden jobs plan would you cut
there's workforce development
there's child care you know all these
different elements of it
cassidy has no answers and instead just
starts slamming teachers unions and it
starts to get pretty unhinged take a
look
up on the screen a hundred billion
dollars for workforce development
400 billion dollars to care for the
elderly and disabled
225 billion dollars for child care
and 200 billion dollars for free
preschool senator
which of those programs that i just put
up which of those programs do you think
people in your state don't need
every one of those programs should be
evaluated if it's important it should be
advanced
it's not infrastructure when people say
wait a second i like this because we
need a new bridge across the kaukasu
river in lake charles
i'm saying this plan will not give it to
you
the amount of spending for roads and
bridges is so low
that and split between 50 states over
five years
you're not going to get your bridge now
we may need this
by the way we just are restarting our uh
our our bipartisan working group to come
at
family support for the dependent
children and elderly
but that is not going to give you a road
and bridge and that's what people in my
state would really like to see
okay so so far he doesn't say any of the
programs are bad
but he says they're not infrastructure
but again this is a jobs plan they're
all job
related uh and they are you know
education
developing a workforce these are even i
would argue parts of infrastructure in
the 21st century
but then cassidy says well this won't
get
my constituents all the things they want
this money is going to go to all 50
states
that's not really a reason to oppose the
bill
unless your expectation is that all the
money
goes to your state but that's not how
federal spending works
and it's not infrastructure but again
it's a jobs bill so so far
this is the lightest questioning in
other countries you would be
ridiculed as a journalist if you didn't
ask these
questions and in the united states with
these unprepared buffoons
just asking the obvious questions gets
you to a point of realizing this this
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
let's continue yeah but but i guess the
question is
and you know we could argue and i have
uh back and forth with both sides about
infrastructure but there are a lot of
programs
that aren't infrastructure and the
question i'm asking you is
should would you support the government
paying for them i mean
i i looked into it in your state of
louisiana
the the rate of child poverty is 25
one in four of the children in louisiana
are in poverty and according to the
white house
42 percent of residents in
louisiana do not have access to
child care so don't they want wouldn't
they benefit
forget whether it's infrastructure or
not wouldn't they benefit from these
government programs
so i don't know if they would if you
think about the main driver of
elevating out of poverty it's good
education
now what we saw in the pandemic was
teachers unions keeping schools shut
even when the centers for disease
control said it was safe to go back
the president wants to give universal
pre-k run by the same teachers unions
now if you're in chicago and there's
more money going to the school systems
into the unions
and yet they still won't open so he's
asked specifically
child poverty is a real problem in
louisiana child poverty is a problem in
the united states
it's an even bigger problem in louisiana
and this bill
helps child poverty isn't that something
to be glad
that the bill addresses well i don't
know says cassidy
teachers unions forced schools to close
during the pandemic
zero substantive engagement
with the topics at hand and then it
continues to just be an alternate
reality
wallace shows cassidy you know the trump
tax cuts you supported
speaking of spending those tax cuts
disproportionately help the rich
and they increase the deficit which he
claims to be concerned about
now when it's joe biden and cassidy
ignores the substance and says oh you
know unemployment rates were really low
before the pandemic
i want to take a look at those tax cuts
according to the tax policy center
the average first year tax cut for a
household making less than twenty five
thousand dollars the average tax cut was
just sixty dollars
the average tax cut for a household
making 3.4
million dollars was 193 000
and contrary to talk that it will pay
for itself the trump tax cuts
are now projected to add one and a half
trillion dollars to the deficit
over 10 years senator of the 2 million
tax filers in louisiana only
14 000 of them were paying more
filing gross income of more than 500 000
so what's wrong with raising
the top tax rate to where it was during
the bush 43 and obama administrations
in order to help the working and middle
class
if all you do is look at first degree
effects
chris you can make a point like that it
sounds just like president biden
speaking at this speak in the congress
and i'm not accusing you i'm just
pointing that out
if you look at the overall effect the
aspiration of
this biden administration is to return
to the economy we had before
covet where we had record low
unemployment which means record high
employment for african americans
veterans women hispanics the disabled
so after throwing in that shot about hey
chris you sound like joe biden
because you're asking real questions
cassidy tries to argue that that deficit
increase thanks to trump's tax cuts
is only a first order effect and then
you know the second order effects would
be that the economy grows so much that
the tax cut pays for itself
it simply didn't happen the deficit
increased and then it increased more and
okay then covet hit but we know that the
tax cuts for the rich
are not revenue positive even in the
long term it's been studied for decades
and then cassidy says as evidence look
at job creation
before the pandemic but after trump's
tax cuts remember once again
job creation under trump was just a
slightly slowed down continuation of
what we saw under barack obama
slowed down his 2017 tax bill
didn't go into effect until 2018 which
was reflected in people's taxes filed in
this the timeline does not add up let's
look at just the last bit here and there
does seem to be like a child crying in
the background during this piece that
that's not
that's part of the clip high school
dropouts with
wage growth disproportionately in the
lower
and the lower quintiles of the income
structure that's where we were seeing
the economy
really help now that was all part of the
tax cut and jobs act bill
you can't separate them and so if you
want to say my gosh these people are
making more money
uh why don't we return and keep the tax
cut in jobs act
that's that's the flip side of the
question you're asking
and i think that flip side is the part
that should be emphasized
but the argument is and there certainly
is some data to indicate that the trump
tax cuts benefited
the wealthy and corporations more than
they did the working
and middle class chris wallace is trying
but this is simply going nowhere they do
not have
answers for any of this they simply
move on to something else which programs
would you cut
doesn't say but bashes teachers unions
teachers unions are bad
well what about the deficit oh yeah but
job creation in 2017 was was really
great
it's pathetic and they should be
subjected to this type of questioning in
every interview
my sense is if this became the standard
on fox news
a lot of these officials would stop
doing fox news interviews and indeed
my understanding is that there are
increasingly republicans who are turning
down interviews with chris wallace
because he's just asking basic questions
that any reporter in just about
every country would be expected to ask
they fall apart the talking points never
made sense
but if there's no pushback in fact
sometimes it's not that there isn't
pushback from the hosts
it's they cheerlead they oh right of
course yeah right right yeah but
democrats don't don't understand that
but yes of course you're right senator
uh as soon as there's basic pushback
they fall apart we'll have more
examples like this on our
instagram page which you can follow at
david pakman show
the great daniel goleman will be joining
me after this short break
really looking forward to this interview
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world-famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial-free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today it's great to
welcome to the program today
daniel goldman who is of course well
known for his writings on emotional
intelligence on meditation a number of
other topics that that are very
interesting to me
it's great to have you on today thanks
david pleasure to be here
so maybe maybe just to start the
conversation we're hopefully starting to
get to
the beginning of the end or the the end
of the middle or some somewhere closer
to
where life will in some ways return to
normal vis-a-vis the pandemic
but one of the things i've been talking
with many people about um
are kind of speculating about what the
longer term effects might be
of this pandemic i think certainly some
degree of of uh
the feeling that the world is a hostile
place which may connect to some
agoraphobia for many people
people may be realizing that the risks
that they were taking before were bigger
than maybe they acknowledged and
changing behavior
going forward it's just some ideas how
are you conceiving of this kind of
exit process and what the impacts may be
emotionally psychologically
well i see two upsides uh
comings at some point one is that
everybody's been under tremendous stress
because of the lockdown
particularly working parents i mean how
do you work from home and manage kids
running in and out of your zoom you know
and you know life goes on
and that just is um raises the stress
level
to a point where people may be feeling
emotionally exhausted
uh and that hopefully will be relieved
when
things ease up the second is a kind of
disconnect
we haven't been able to see our friends
you know hanging out
in the way we usually do and zoom or
or skype you know these video
conferencing
ways of meeting people do something
a little weird to the social circuitry
of the brain
and that is i can't look you in the eye
at the same time i see your face
if you're right you're either looking at
the camera if you look at the camera
it looks like you're looking at me but
then you're not really looking at where
you see me on your screen yeah
exactly so the the disconnect
is that there's no eye contact anymore
at least on screen and we'll be able to
have that again what a relief
to the extent we can see people and
you're right people still have to be
safe i'm double vaccinated and we just
saw some friends outside
still with masks you know i'm of an age
where i might be vulnerable i've got to
be very careful and
people need to be careful too not just
for themselves but for p
other people they love and contact
regularly but then
the big unanswered question is the one
you raise
what will be the long-term consequences
of
having not been able to see people as
usual
i think on children and teenagers
because the social emotional circuitry
of the brain
is the last part of the brain to become
anatomically mature
it doesn't get set in place until the
mid-twenties
and at every stage children
and teens need something there's what's
called the five to seven
shift when kids prefrontal
cortex comes online and circuitry that
allows them to
just say no to emotional impulse gets
stronger and stronger
but then as they develop they need to be
with other kids kids learn an immense
amount
emotionally and socially from their
peers
and all of a sudden it's gone and we
don't know
what the consequences would be i tend to
be an optimist i tend to think
well you know kids are really adept
at remedial learning and i hope that
turns out to be true we just don't know
yeah from from a strictly mathematical
standpoint
a 30-year-old being home for a year and
a 60 year old being home for a year as a
proportion of their lives
is very different than someone that was
six
and from six to seven that's you know
that's more than fifteen percent of of
their lives
is that kind of relative uh
comparison important in thinking about
who might
suffer the the biggest impact in a sense
perhaps
what that mathematics does not factor in
is the rate at which children might be
able to make up for what they didn't get
and you know you see this uh children
are
children's brains are remarkably plastic
that way
so we have a model of uh the
the family unit two parents you know and
a kid or kids
as being essential but actually the
human brain was designed for all kinds
of tragedies
maybe your parents get killed uh you
know maybe
someone else takes care of you you can
learn the same things from the caretaker
that you would have
from your parent that's the way the
brain is designed so
we'll see uh how adept
kids are at undoing what what has been
done to them
one of the things i've been noticing
myself is now as someone who's
double vaccinated and i'm following all
the cdc guidelines which now include
that
unless you're in a big crowd outdoors
you don't have to wear a mask president
joe biden telling us this the cdc
telling us this last year but yet i
still find myself thinking even though i
know i'm following all the guidelines
when someone else goes by without a mask
there's a second where my mind does
something where i say whoa hold on this
is this is dangerous in some way
but then i remember hold on a second at
the worst case
one out of a thousand cases were being
transmitted outdoors the person's 20
feet away
i've been conditioned in a sense to
perceive danger maybe where there is not
is that something that you expect will
persist for some time
well david you're you're very um
probabilistically oriented yes thinking
and that's a kind of a cognitive control
you're reframing the situation i
completely agree
and not many people can do that lots of
people just react
viscerally they don't have the cognitive
wherewithal to
to say well it's one in a thousand and
it's outdoors and so on
so um i think people will be
reacting now and for some time from
their emotional centers rather
rationally and cognitively you've been
uh doing
more and more work or at least i've been
seeing more and more of your work
related to meditation of late and
i've been studying with great interest
some of the research that is done into
the effects of meditation
on the brain and there are all sorts of
different opinions about is the effect
overstated or understated or do we not
yet really know
whether in the context of the pandemic
or not can you talk a little bit about
your focus on on meditation and why you
think it's an important thing for
in particular now well i think it's a
natural next step
from emotional intelligence you know
emotional intelligence says
and my model has four parts there's
self-awareness
and then using that awareness to manage
your disturbing emotions well and
martial positive ones well it turns out
that meditation is a very good tool for
doing that
it is an exercise in self-awareness and
i just did a book with richard davidson
who's a neuroscientist at
the university of wisconsin and we
looked at the very best studies and we
found from the beginning
people tend to be more calm and more
clear if they meditate
and there's a dose response effect so
that the longer you do it the more hours
you put in
the more this seems to happen long-term
meditators are
triggered less often
less severely and recover more quickly
we found
from the data and very high you know
olympic level meditators are a whole
other thing
and it turns out that if you do an
exercise
that increases warm-heartedness
compassion or caring
you become more compassionate caring
it's kind of a no-brainer but it turns
out that the part of
the brain actually that
where those circuits reside becomes
stronger and that
behaviorally you're more likely to help
someone in need you're more generous
and so on so meditation seems to work
and the second part of emotional
intelligence
is empathy and i'm i'm
rethinking emotional intelligence now uh
if i can i mention my podcast please of
course yeah it's available
i just started a podcast called first
person singular
where some of my newest thinking is
uh shared with people and one of the
ways i'm rethinking it
is in terms of what is empathy i know
it's cognitive
i know it's emotional but it also is
empathic concern
which means you care about the other
person not just you know how they think
you know how they feel
but you want what's best for them it's
like a parent's love for a child
and i think this leads to compassion or
to
that whole unfolding of warm-heartedness
yeah i mean what's very interesting to
me about this and i don't want to make
everything political and i'm glad not to
but
one of the things that i've been i've
been reading quite a bit about is that
um on well-designed sort of assessments
of the level of empathy
and compassion that are triggered in
people when they are told a particular
story or see a particular image
it can very accurately predict
one's political leanings on a sort of
general conservative
liberal uh spectrum as we might imagine
it in the united states applies to
democrats and republicans and then
the next question sort of becomes how
much of this is nature how much is
nurture how much is
the environment you grew up around and
kind of what your parents modeled for
you versus is there something in the
brain and different people have
different opinions
in theory at least this could be very
relevant from a policy standpoint could
it not
you know it it reminds me of some data i
saw years ago when i was a science
journalist at the new york times
and it was a behavioral genetic study
of different behavioral variables one of
which was conservatism
which turned out to have a very high
heritability
which suggests that part of this may be
in our inherited circuitry
the tendency to want things to be safe
to want things to be
the same and then translate that into a
political orientation
and then the policy question becomes a
very interesting one
but not one i'm an expert on so i'm
gonna finesse it david
well no but i guess i mean from this
from the standpoint that is more
more relevant to your work there is that
question of when we say heritability
is it genetically heritable versus is it
culturally heritable my
instinct would be that and that
while there may be a genetic
heritability
if you take a group of kids that's
statistically more likely to be
republicans from you know utah or
something like that
but you raise them in liberal
massachusetts families my
instinct is that the upbringing will
have a significant impact
even on whatever genetic heritability is
there i don't know i'm thinking out loud
yeah david i agree with you it's always
nurture as well as nature
and uh how kids are brought up or the
culture you're
socialized into has a great impact on
how you behave
even given a you know xyz
inherited tendency so i
i with you i think it would matter but
we don't know
do you um do do you take an evolutionary
perspective at all
on human empathy uh because i've read
a lot one way or the other about the the
evolutionary advantage
of empathy uh and there are there's the
position that it's sort of vestigial
that
that an advantage that was at one point
relevant may no longer be today
i don't know is that something you think
about
well i i tend to take an evolutionary
perspective
and uh from my from that point of view
uh empathy has a real upside because
when humans started living in groups and
cooperating
which takes empathy uh you know teamwork
basically
made humans uh the species that was a
standout
regrettably uh evolution did not foresee
the predicament we're in now
where uh our economics the everyday
things we buy and use are degrading the
the ecosystem we depend on to survive
and i think that will become a more and
more compelling
reality for younger generations as time
goes on
i think it will reverberate back into
the
uh business world and that
corporations companies will be find it
is in their best interest to do things
in a better way for the environment
because they want to keep market share
and people will care
do you think that there's or is there a
particular
uh lens that you think is a valuable
lens
to think about the issues you work on
that's essentially missing right now
from the national conversation in other
words if you are
sort of going to uh the typical news
sources
and informed by what people see on
social media some
some aspect of thinking about the
society in which we now live
that's not really getting the attention
it deserves that you think would be
a great thing if it did i call it
radical transparency
and i mean ecological transparency
and i actually i just did a podcast on
this it's an idea who i think whose time
has come
basically right now we have full
transparency about the cost
of products we have zero transparency
about the ecological impacts of products
so if you were to buy a new mic or a new
shirt uh ideally
and the methodology for this exists you
could know
the full environmental impact of that
over its full life cycle and you would
know that a point of purchase
this this is the ideal and
it might happen one day and i think it
may be expedited by younger generations
the reason being
the uh coming climate crisis
which is being the engine of which
has been our economic system let's see
if we can
do an example of that so we know that a
lot of clothing is now really cheap and
we intuitively know
that part of the reason it's inexpensive
is
it's produced uh in countries with
very that pay very low wages and um
that is why we are able to get a shirt
for seven dollars that maybe would
otherwise cost
thirty dollars the idea of the
transparency you're talking about would
be
when you see the seven dollar price tag
of the
sri lankan made shirt it might have
something there that says
the full product life cycle makes this
really
a forty dollar shirt now i as the buyer
may not
be out of pocket for the additional 33
dollars
but it would at least be available to me
to know that that cost
is part of this purchase and it may be
more expensive
than the 30 u.s made shirt i mean in
theory to come up with just an example
of what you mean
yeah so i would i think that the
ecological transparency would probably
be more powerful when you're choosing
between a seven dollar and a ten dollar
shirt um
and you find out that the 10
shirt uh is made with alternative energy
and uh is made with cotton which
is not grown in a place where water is
super scarce and
right it's driving people away because
of that
and the factory that it was made in
actually pays a decent wage rather than
starvation wage and you may think well
you know i'm going to do some good with
that extra three bucks
and i'm gonna buy the ten dollar shirt
rather than the seven dollar shirt and i
think that will
start to show that transparency would
shift market share
so that the guy who's making the seven
dollar shirt can say
hey why aren't people buying my shirts
and find out and say okay well i'm going
to do this and this and this
and then get certified by an independent
body
that he's improved and then he's now
again competitive with the 10
shirt that's interesting i mean i think
you're right that
the comparison is much easier the
decision is much easier when it's 7
versus 10
but maybe that's some of the difficulty
as well because i don't
you know i don't know enough about the
production of shirts to know this but
it's conceivable that the difference
would be far bigger and so
the the financial impact on an
individual
might be less trivial than maybe seven
to ten dollars might be
i actually think that uh in in the
actual competitive arena of companies
yeah who are looking at their supply
chain how they extract
how they manufacture they would do
incremental changes
and so you know the two seven dollar
shirts would say hey my sub dollar shirt
doesn't isn't going to threaten the the
uh climate
that guys is right in other words that's
more likely
to be the arena and look you know
another interesting example is our cell
phones
everybody's got one these days and
who knew that they all have rare earths
as they're called some of which are
mined in places that have slave labor
yes yes well darn
you know what are you going to do about
that if we had transparency about that
i think that that could change yeah a
lot of ways in which transparency
and it's really bizarre because one of
the
fundamental principles of the free
market economy
is transparency and and there is zero
transparency yeah yeah i think you know
the
the electric car example is an
interesting one because
i think this is being improved upon but
the footprint of making the batteries is
not insignificant
and then what you do with the batteries
after the fact is
i think we're closer to solving that but
the disposal is also significant
and that is is completely opaque i think
to most
uh most electric car buyers and plastics
is the same
if you were to do a life cycle
assessment of plastic
and that's what this method is called it
would look like plastic
bags are better than brown paper bags
but that's because the
life cycle assessment does not include
end of life right
and plastics as we now are finding out
are in us and
fish and birds and everything else uh
and it's a huge problem that we had not
realized so
anyway you asked what's missing and i
think that's what's missing
that's a great example yeah that's a
that's a beautiful note to uh to to end
on we've been speaking with daniel
goldman we will link to
the podcast as well as uh some some of
his books
daniel such a pleasure having you on i
so appreciate your time
david it's a real pleasure thank you
very much
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
david pakman show we have something very
dangerous going on
uh not only do we have anti-vaccine
conspiracies
spreading at exactly a time when
we most need to be vaccinating people so
that we can be done with this horrifying
pandemic
we actually are seeing anti-vaccine
nonsense
do so well among the american right wing
that right-wing media is trying to
one-up each other
as to who can be the most anti-vaccine
and we covered fox news host tucker
carlson's anti-mass
comments last week we covered podcast
host joe rogan's anti-vaccine
comments as well i'm almost wondering
whether tucker carlson
was jealous about the attention that joe
rogan was getting last week
because last night joe uh not joe tucker
went even further off the deep end into
a completely unhinged
baseless and deceptive anti-vaccine rant
that unfortunately is having an impact
now for people saying why are we talking
about this we are talking about this
because we are now at a point
where people just don't want to get the
vaccine and daily doses have been
declining for about 10 days now even
we're only at 44 of the country has had
one dose
32 percent of the country has had full
vaccination
vaccination should be increasing right
now but it's declining
because people uh are increasingly
not interested in getting the vaccine
from those that have not yet
received any of the doses so let's get
into the first
outrageous vaccine related clip from
last night that does not mean that they
are dangerous and we are not claiming
the chronos virus vaccines are dangerous
but we are telling the truth which is
there are
unresolved concerns about their
long-term effects on some
people including their effects on female
fertility
so first of all there's an image behind
tucker that says mandatory vaccinations
now there are no
mandatory vaccinations some schools have
said if you want to come to the school
you'll need to be vaccinated yes
and there there will be a businesses
that may decide if you want to do
business with us you you will need a
vaccine but there are no
mandatory vaccinations from from
government it's just not happening
nobody's forcing anyone to get a vaccine
now the female fertility question is one
that has been raised but it is without
evidence
there is simply no evidence that the
vaccine impacts female fertility
now tucker says well we don't know it
hasn't been studied it would be like if
i
say we don't know the long-term effect
of the vaccine
uh on curling skill you know the olympic
sport curling
i mean yeah it's true it's not been
studied
but we have no reason to think that the
vaccine
impacts how good you are going to be at
olympic curling
uh and then he gets into some more
specific claims that are also deceptive
take a look
that is not a conspiracy theory that is
true
it's an honest question what's the
long-term effect that no one so far has
been able to answer
and it's not simply being asked by
partisans it's being asked by practicing
physicians
catherine lee for example is a research
fellow in the division of public health
sciences
at washington university in st louis lee
doesn't seem like a partisan republican
or a q a on adherent or a crank she
gladly took the chronovirus vaccine
she seems to support the chronovirus
vaccine strongly
but then in herself she noticed
unexpected effects on her menstrual
cycle
quote it wasn't a symptom that was on
the list lee said
i expected that my arm would be sore or
that i might have a fever or headache
but this just wasn't on the list kate
clancy another scientist who studies
female fertility at the university of
illinois
reported that she had the same symptoms
after she got the vaccine and she wrote
about it in some detail on twitter you
can look it up
after she did write about it dozens of
other women wrote in about similar
experiences
they had had after getting the vaccine
none of these symptoms had been
described in the medical literature
the reason the clinical trials for the
vaccines never tested for the effects on
the female menstrual cycle or for
fertility or on pregnant women
so maybe the symptoms amount to nothing
that's often the case
maybe they amount to something we don't
know
the fact is we can't say with the
long-term effects of this vaccine will
be
on women including pregnant women now
you really have to pick
each thing apart there the statements
by katherine lee and kate clancy
about the heavy periods after the
vaccine
those are true statements tucker is
accurately quoting them
but it's not complete we know
first of all that menstrual cycles are
heavily affected
by stress of all kinds vaccines work
directly on the immune system the
menstrual cycle is very sensitive
to anything that affects the immune
system i know women who have mentioned
experiencing this
then they went back to normal after one
cycle after being vaccinated
what tucker is not telling you
is that the very same doctor catherine
lee that he quotes
also said this would have no effect on
fertility
tucker tells you look dr catherine lee
said whoa
heavy period but katherine lee
also said this will have no effect on
fertility and tucker doesn't tell you
that he's only giving you a partial
quote
and then tucker shifts into saying no
one is allowed to ask
questions honest people admit this
every scientist knows it according to a
recent study published in the new
england journal of medicine quote
more longitudinal follow-up including
follow-up of large numbers of women
vaccinated earlier in pregnancy
is necessary to inform maternal
pregnancy and
infant outcomes in other words at this
point and there's no changing this
because it's true
we just don't know again that does not
mean the coronavirus vaccine
is dangerous there is no proof that it's
dangerous
but there doesn't need to be now i have
to tell you
this is pretty sophisticated propaganda
in total
we can see through it but it but it's
actually quite sophisticated tucker
opens by saying
i'm not anti-vaccine he ends by saying
it's these vaccines may well be safe but
in between
he puts out carefully truncated partial
statements from doctors about vaccine
side effects
with pictures above his shoulders that
say mandatory vaccinations which don't
exist
no questions allowed as if someone is
silencing him
even though he's been doing this now for
weeks it's really pretty sophisticated
propaganda let's look at one more clip
nbc news is now running and you may have
seen these psas public service
announcements with its on-air talent
demanding that everyone in the country
get the shot barack obama just released
this creepy little video telling small
children to get the shot hi everybody
it's barack now that every american over
the age of 16 is eligible to get the
vaccine
i want to talk about you getting yours
the vaccine is safe
it's effective it's free i got one
michelle got one people you know got one
and now you can get one too
it's the only way we're going to get
back to all the things we love
from safely spending time with
grandparents to going to concerts and
watching live sports
so get the vaccine as soon as you can
some creepy old guy telling your
children your little kids to take
medicine whose effects
we do not fully understand it's totally
normal yeah that that happens every day
don't ask questions just do it as cnn
explained
recently we're not getting our freedom
back
until you do the funny thing is trump
said the same thing as obama just not at
all
eloquently it's not about we can't ask
questions
it's the questions have been asked and
they've been answered
trump said during that weird interview
in march i think with sean hannity i got
the vaccine people should get it
i don't know why people don't want to
get it it's essentially what barack
obama said no one's being forced obama
obama's just more eloquent
in saying it and that seems to really
anger tucker carlson but tucker only
talks about barack obama saying go and
get vaccinated
when donald trump also said go and get
vaccinated on the hannity program
in a much less articulate and less
eloquent way sure
so this is really dangerous stuff
because tucker's audience
is made up disproportionately of people
who are vaccine skeptical
republicans at this point the most
coveted vaccine skeptical group out
there
and this is going to make it even worse
at a time when we just
we have the ability look at the israeli
numbers
uh they had i think 13 cases or
something like that
same size and population as new jersey
we can do it but people like tucker
carlson are making it more difficult
absolute chaos took place in kansas over
a republican elected official
who was apparently moonlighting as a
substitute teacher
and is accused of kicking a student as
we used to say
in the balls or in the balls as you know
who used to say
among all sorts of other wild and wacky
things i'm talking about kansas state
representative
mark samsel yes he's a republican
he filled in at wellsville high school
in wellsville kansas
last wednesday samsel represents this
very area
in the state legislature that includes
wellsville and the school
samsel apparently went bonkers trying to
push
what is a kind of pseudo-religious
agenda on the children he was berating
some of the teenagers
he was pleading with them to follow god
he was asking them about their
masturbation habits was demanding that
the children
make babies because it quote feels
good and claiming that a sophomore at
the school
must be contemplating suicide because
they have lesbian parents
and then as if that's not enough things
really got
nuts for lack of a better term when
samsung
allegedly grabbed one student
pushed him against the wall attacked
another by invoking the quote wrath of
god
hitting him intentionally in the
testicles
and then inviting others in the class to
do the same
here is some of the rant which was
caught on video and audio
make babies who likes making babies that
feels good doesn't
it procreate
he says encourage it you haven't
masturbated
don't answer that question i'm not gonna
answer you know thank you i told you not
to
god doesn't god already knows
do you believe me when i tell you that
god has been speaking to me
i could put the wrath of god on you
right now that's what you're telling me
to do
you should run and scream because the
devil's getting the hell out of my
bathroom
and you're gonna hurt worse than
childhood which is another part
you have permission to kick him in the
balls
so who put together the bible multiple
stories from different people
it wasn't even just one it was multiple
different editors tried to combine all
the stories
while there were distractions from the
demo
you know i had some pretty wacky
substitute teachers in elementary school
and middle school and high school never
anything
remotely close to this that's for sure
he has since
admitted that he planned his actions
but says he did nothing wrong i don't
know what that means
the 36 year old republican was arrested
on charges of alleged
misdemeanor battery already a lot of
people who saw the video saying
there has to be a felony in there how is
this only misdemeanors
he was booked into the franklin county
adult detention center
he's been released on a thousand dollars
bond now in case you were wondering the
superintendent ryan bradbury
said samsel will no longer be substitute
teaching in the school district
i'm curious how the kansas republican
party will respond to this they've
i've not heard anything from them at
this point some people wrote to me and
said you know david this is not really
about politics or religion this is a
psychotic break
this is merely a mental health incident
he just sort of happens to be obsessed
with things like
accepting god but there's really nothing
political here
i agree that this is not a stable and
well-balanced person there's no question
about it
uh beyond that there's there remain
questions
and in a later snapchat post samsul
reportedly claimed
that quote every little bit of it was
planned
to send a message about art mental
health
teenage suicide how we treat our
educators and one another to parents
and grandparents of wellsville so
i guess going to i the kids and i
we did this together uh to send some
kind of a message
a very strange way to send a message for
sure
and we will follow the court uh
proceedings and see what ultimately
takes place
we have a voicemail number that you
should feel more than welcome to call
any time of day that number is 2192
david p
here's a good question asking about
about uh whatever
became of the andrew cuomo scandal in
new york
hi david uh quick question for you um
why are we hearing anything more about
andrew cuomo
news every day a couple weeks ago
was allegation after allegation new
woman coming out saying that
he did something inappropriate now boom
gone i know this is a another on a long
line of
news stories that has dried up into the
ether
what's your take on it my take is not
that different
than what's been going on with matt
gates which is the matt gates story has
also sort of taken a back seat
um i i think that there are these kind
of lulls
where not l-u-l-z right l-u-l-l-s
to be clear um we learn about an
investigation
and then there's a period where the
investigation is happening and unless
there's something to keep the story in
the news corporate media just lets it go
and my expectation is that um when
this all uh gets closer to a conclusion
or there is some
some uh final determination and i'm
talking both about matt gates whether
there will be charges
and the investigation into andrew cuomo
that it'll be back in the news i think
it's it's that simple uh there's other
shiny objects that corporate media has
moved on to
we will talk about the task of
fact-checking joe biden on today's bonus
show
kroger will also be starting drone
deliveries in ohio this week
what will it how will it look uh what
will it look like how will it work
and also the united states has started
to reunite some families separated at
the mexico border we will tell you how
it's being done
and what we can expect plus much more
including
producer pat's full fallout
from vaccination dose number two which
he received yesterday and born yesterday
in the morning
all of that and more on today's bonus
show don't miss it
get a membership at joinpakman.com to
get instant access
and i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman